[Music]
my name is D Kila I'm the CEO at
contextual Ai and I'm here to talk to
you about rag in production rag agents
specifically um and I'll I'll share some
of the lessons that I've learned so my
background is in AI research uh but
after that I became the CEO of a AI
company focus on Enterprise so I thought
I would share some of my learnings with
you uh in the hope that that's
useful so if you uh look at Enterprise
AI uh if you work in this space you
probably notice that there's a huge
opportunity uh ahead of us right
everybody wants to grab that opportunity
there's there's these huge numbers
flying around $4.4 trillion is is the
estimated added value to the global
economy according to to McKenzie so we
have this giant opportunity but at the
same time if you actually look at what's
happening in Enterprises you see a lot
of frustration it's probably even true
for some of the people in the audience
right here if you're a VP of AI then
you're probably under some pressure
right now it's like where's the ROI
we're investing all this money in AI but
where is it actually leading us to are
we getting something out of this so uh
Forbes has this interesting study where
they showed that only one in four or
businesses actually get value from AI so
why is that happening right it feels a
bit like a
paradox uh so to to explain it we can
look uh at a paradox that might be
familiar to you it's it's something
called morx Paradox it's from Robotics
and in robotics they were very surprised
when they found out that it's actually
much easier to beat humans at chess than
to have a robot that can vacuum clean
your house or have a self-driving
car um so the the the Paradox here is
really that things that seem hard are
actually much easier for computers than
you would expect and things that seem
easy actually turn out to be much harder
right so there's something very similar
happening right now in in Enterprise AI
specifically and this is around context
so on the one hand we have these amazing
language models right you You' that's
why we're all here basically because we
see this revolution happening right in
front of our eyes so language models can
generate code much better than most
humans they can solve mathematical
problems much better than than most of
us here can do uh and we're pretty smart
um so it's really amazing what they can
do but one of the things that they
really still struggle with and that's
one of the things that as humans we are
very good at sort of without effort is
putting things in the right context
right so as humans we build on our
expertise we build on our intuition that
we've developed over the years
especially if we're a specialist this is
something that is very easy easy for us
to do is to put something in the right
context and um and in the right
situation so that you can make sense of
the information or the problem that
you're
solving so I would argue that this is
really the key observation this this
context Paradox um for unlocking Roi
with AI and the reason for that is that
where we are right now here is is in the
bottom left right so we're we're mostly
focused on convenience we have general
purpose assistance they're very use
mostly if you're lazy they help you sort
of solve your problems faster but where
you really want to get to is
differentiated value if you're an
Enterprise it's nice that you can make
things more convenient you probably can
make people more efficient and more
productive that's great but where you
want to get to is this business
transformation ideal right that's what
all the CEOs are probably telling you as
a VP of AI like I want to change my
entire business how am I going to do
that so getting to that differentiated
value that's where you want to get to
but the problem is that the higher you
go on that axis the further you go on
the context axis so the the better you
need to be at handling the context uh uh
that exists within your
Enterprise um so what should we do about
that um so that observation is really
why I started the company that I'm
currently the the CEO of contextual AI
um and we started this two years ago to
try to help bridge this Gap um and we've
learned some lessons along the way that
I thought I would share with you uh in
the hope that they're also useful for
you so the first observation is really
that language models are awesome but
often they're only 20% of a much bigger
system um so if you have an Enterprise
AI deployment usually that means it's a
rag system uh so I I think everybody
here probably has heard of rag uh rag is
something that I uh originally pioneered
with my team at Facebook a research when
I was there uh so rag is is really kind
of the standard way that you get gen to
work on your data so what happens very
often these days is a new language model
comes out everybody goes whoa new
language model it's great everybody
starts to think just about the language
model but very few people actually think
about the system around the language
model and that system needs to solve the
problem right so you can have a
relatively mediocre language model but
an amazing rag pipeline around it and
that's going to be much better than an
amazing language model with a terrible
rag pipeline around it so the basic
observation here or the lesson is that
you should be thinking about systems not
about models the model is only a small
part of the system and the system is the
thing that solves the
problem the next observation is that if
you're in an Enterprise expertise is
really your fuel right so uh one of the
the things that you want to be able to
do as an Enterprise is unlock all of
that expertise so you have all of this
institutional knowledge in your company
how do you get it out um so one way to
try to do that is is using these
generalist kind of general purpose
assistant but it's very hard to get them
to to uh to match the expertise of
people in your company so ideally what
you want to do is to specialize so that
you can capture that expertise much
better so uh at my company we call this
specialization over AGI AGI is great
there are lots of use cases for it if
you really want to solve a very
difficult problem that is very domain
specific where you understand the use
case you to specialize for it and you'll
get much further so that's I guess uh
pretty counterintuitive if you look at
the sort of broader uh interest right
most people are much more excited about
AGI but solving real problems is much
easier with
specialization uh next lesson is uh at
an Enterprise scale is your remote so if
you think about what a company really is
is a company maybe its people probably a
little bit right but over time what the
company really is or what makes a
company a company is it's data because
even people are transient right so the
data that a company owns that is the
company in the long term so now as an
Enterprise you need to think how you can
unlock all of that potential right and
so U one of the the big issues that we
see a lot is that enterprises think that
uh you need to scrub the data and clean
it and invest a lot of time in in uh
making your data accessible with AI but
what you really want to do is make sure
that AI can work on your noisy data at
scale and doing that is incredibly
difficult but if you succeed in doing
that that's how you get to
differentiated value right that's how
you get that mode because the data makes
makes your company your company and so
that data is really your
mode uh one observation uh and this is
really a hard truth that that we've
learned and I think that many of you
might have learned already or that
you're about to find out uh if you're
earlier in in your journey is that
Pilots are very easy uh building a Mo
not very difficult these days right if
you want to build a rag system you take
one of the Frameworks you put in some
documents you have a working solution
it's great you give it to your 10 users
they all tell you it's fantastic and
then you show it to the CEO and he says
okay we're going to fire half the
customer support team and we're going to
replace them with AI and we're going to
do that in three months and now you're
on the hook for productionizing
something that is actually much much
harder right so getting this to work at
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands or millions of documents you
can't do that with any existing tools uh
that are out there on the open source
market it's very very difficult to do
that making the skill to thousands of
users is very hard uh making it work for
lots of different use cases if you're an
Enterprise maybe you have 20,000
different use cases that you want to
cover so how do you scale if that's the
problem that you're solving and then
there's of course Enterprise
requirements around security and and
compliance so bridging that Gap is much
harder than you think and and the the
right way to deal with that is to really
focus on production from day one so
don't design for the pilot design for
production uh and that can save you a
lot of time and that brings me to the
next observation is that speed is really
much more important than Perfection what
we see um in terms of production
rollouts of uh rag agents it's all about
speed um and and what that means is uh
you need to give it to your users
relatively early real users not not sort
of uh testers who are are kind of
friendly you want to give it to real
users to get their feedback you want to
do that early it doesn't have to be
perfect it just needs to be barely
functional and if you do that then you
can Hill Climb to actually get to this
level where it's good enough if you
don't do that and you wait too long and
then you try to design something that is
perfect it's going to be very hard to to
bridge that Gap from Pilot to production
so iteration is really the key to a lot
of uh successful uh production AI
deployments in in Enterprises
next observation is is related to this
too which is that uh if you want your
engineers to be fast and if you want to
follow that that speed Maxim I just
talked about then you don't want them
work working on boring stuff uh sounds
kind of obvious but it turns out that
Engineers are working on a lot of very
boring stuff um and so one of one of the
the things that they have to worry about
for example is what is the optimal
chunking strategy for my rag system and
it's different for every use case and
it's different for every framework and
then they have to think about what the
right prompt is or really basic things
that ideally they don't have to think
about too much because you really want
your engineers to think about how are am
I going to deliver business value right
how how do I make sure I have this
differentiated value and that I'm
actually better than my
competitors um so make sure that your
engineers spend time on the things that
matter and not on the chunking strategy
or or things that that can be abstracted
away uh very well these days by by state
ofth artk platforms for for drag
agents next one is is about making AI
easy to consume so what what I mean by
that is we actually see uh this happen
quite often where companies have Genai
running in production and then the next
question I often ask them is okay how
many people are actually using it and
and surprisingly often the answer is
zero almost nobody's actually using it
they did all this work but they had to
make sure it came through uh sort of
model risk and and uh teams like that so
it was really like kneecapped almost and
now it's barely useful uh so that's one
scenario or or very often people just
don't actually know how to use the
technology so it it really is a journey
that you are on uh and the easier you
can make your solutions to consume the
better it is and what that what that
means for most Enterprises is not just
thinking about your Enterprise data and
how you make AI work on it but also how
you integrate it into their workflows so
the closer you can integrate ated into a
workflow that already exists in your
Enterprise the more successful you're
going to be with real production
usage uh next one is is related uh to
the previous one as well uh where it's
really about getting usage it's about
sort of being sticky and and so this
sounds maybe a little obvious but the
the quicker you can wow users or get
this sort of spark where they they
suddenly get it like this for for me as
a CEO of AI company that's really the
special moment when people suddenly go
like wow I didn't know that it could do
this um so you can try to design your
experiences for onboarding users around
this observation too right so where
where they get to the wow as quickly as
possible so for us we had this really
nice example with someone at Qualcomm so
we're we're running in production
globally with Qualcomm with thousands of
customer engineers and one of them
became so happy when they found this
document it was 7 years old it was
hidden away somewhere they didn't know
it existed they had all these questions
and they just never knew what the
answers were and suddenly because they
asked our system they got these answers
and like their their world was never the
same again after that um so these are
the the small the small winds sort of uh
that that really matter for for uh
evangelizing uh production in
AI uh so that brings me to the the
penultimate learning which is that it's
not even really about accuracy anymore
so accuracy is almost table Stakes right
uh so I I think as AI practitioners we
probably know that getting 100% accuracy
is very hard if not impossible getting
95% accuracy maybe you can get there or
90% but what Enterprises are are
thinking about much more these days is
what about the missing 5% or what about
the missing 10% how do I deal with the
things that might go wrong right um so
there's a minimum requirement for
accuracy but beyond that is really about
inaccuracy and the way to deal with that
is through observability so you want to
be very care care f with how you
evaluate these systems you want to be
very careful with making sure you have
proper audit Trails especially if you
work in a regulated industry this is
incredibly important right making sure
that you have an audit Trill that says
this is why I generated this answer it's
because I found it here in this document
basic things like that so attribution
essentially in a rag system actually
becomes very very important for dealing
with the inaccuracies and similarly what
you can do is you can check the claims
that your system generates so do a lot
of postprocessing to ensure that you
have proper attributions uh that that
you can really back up uh as
evidence struggling with the clicker a
bit so uh F final one uh that I want to
end on and this sounds maybe a little
bit cheesy but it it it really is is
true is be ambitious we we actually see
a lot of projects fail not because
people are aiming too high but because
people are aiming too low where where
folks are going like I have gen running
in production and then what does it do
it answers basic questions about who
your 401k provider is or how many days
of vacation I get like that's not really
where the ROI of AI is right so you want
to aim for really ambitious things where
if you solve them you actually have have
Roi and you don't just have a gimmick
that people don't really uh use anyway
so try to be be ambitious because we
really live in special times we have the
the astronaut here on the slide um so so
I I think it was a pretty special time
to be alive during the the moon landing
and when all of that happened right
we're in a in a similar moment right now
where AI is is really going to change
everything is going to change our entire
Society in the next couple of years um
and so you have an opportunity being in
the role that you're in to to Really uh
uh affect that change in society
yourself uh so so be ambitious when you
do that uh and don't aim for the the
loow hanging easy fruit uh aim for for
the sky
so uh that's really U what what my
lessons were for you here uh this
context Paradox is not going away um but
by understanding these lessons that I I
shared with you hopefully you can turn
some of these challenges uh that we see
everywhere in Enterprise AI into
opportunities for yourself um so so it's
really build better systems think about
systems not models focus on your
expertise and specialize for it don't
settle for General Solutions specialize
for for expertise that you have in your
company and be ambitious and then you'll
be very successful thank you
[Applause]
[Music]